sweet home I guess you're not from these  parts we just moved down from New York  no peeking  let's give it another try there's no  reason we can't have children well  already tried twice stop baby stop  nobody told you the previous owners  I got killed in this house house blood  [Music]  honey a real van Gogh yeah sure where  did you get all this stuff the room  makes things why do you need most of the  work I want a million dollars  work who cares how it works you just use  it the only thing more dangerous for the  person who can't get what they want is a  person who gets wherever they get out of  the house before it's too late  where's the necklace you asked for I can  always get another a shortcut you use  the room to make a baby baby he's not a  thing yes you never take that stuff  outdoors of course I am  you're not only the person man wants to  be free but first the Creator must die  you said we'd be together forever mr.  rule come with me  mommy daddy  [Music]  daddy  you